I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are
building This Magnificent family
going on in that head of yours something
little bit he said Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear boom
such a beautiful life filled with love
and family I never got that chance
you stole that from me
my few
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
beat by piece
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
never accept death
praying is old
ER
setup he's trying to tear us apart
when it used to be about winning we
raced for respect
today I race to stop the blood back
the problem with having such a big
family how do you choose the ones you
save
Let's Race
[Music]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
recognizes again
all right
I'm coming for you son
[Music]
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]